all right quick story I don't want to
spend a lot of time on this but it is
funny and it's also sort of emblematic
of some bigger picture issue that we're
dealing with with the president this is
one of those stories that that when you
first see the headline it's hard to
believe but it is a very interesting
microcosm of the childish nature of the
person who's in charge of the White
House right now and we've talked a lot
of times about how Donald Trump in many
ways is like a little kid they bring him
a propaganda file at the White House
full of positive headlines and pictures
where he looks like an alpha male
because that placates Donald Trump this
is kind of like how you treat a little
kid the president presidential daily
briefings have to be reduced to it was
reduced initially to just a couple pages
eventually to one page and then
ultimately to a single page with two or
three bullet points and one or two maps
or graphs otherwise Donald Trump won't
read it or he'll get distracted or he'll
get bored the low attention span stuff
and there is now a new report from the
New York Times where former White House
dr. Ronnie Jackson says he was blending
cauliflower into Donald Trump's mashed
potatoes in order to try to get him to
eat in a slightly more healthy manner
and this is not like an investigative
scoop that may or may not be true Ronnie
Jackson straight-up said this to the New
York Times during an interview and this
was part of a bigger program
apparently Ronnie Jackson wanted Trump
to lose 10 or 15 pounds he wanted to
bring in an exercise bike or an
elliptical to the White House he wanted
to make ice cream more difficult for
Donald Trump to get his hands on and yes
he was putting cauliflower into the
mashed potatoes of Donald Trump now this
is not breaking news in the sense that
this doesn't affect the lives of people
Trump's coronavirus response is
atrocious regardless of what is getting
mixed into his mashed potatoes this is
not about the geopolitical embarrassment
that is Donald Trump on a daily basis
but it is yet again another one of those
little details that shows us that at
every level at the micro at the macro
and everywhere in between Donald Trump
is like a child and people are
around him deal with him like peep and
people often deal with children
I actually know people raising kids who
hide cauliflower in mashed potatoes who
make pizzas out of cauliflower crusts
instead of actual pizza dough who will
blend red peppers and put them into
marinara sauce when they make pasta for
their kids much the same way that Donald
Trump is being handled here and when I
saw the headline I assumed it was an
absolute and total joke
it's all too real this is real it's not
about fat shaming this is about nothing
other than in every way world leaders
deal with Trump like dealing with a
little kid the people who need to brief
Trump at the White House deal with him
like the low attention span little kid
that can only focus on stuff for a
couple minutes at a time there is
nothing about dealing with Trump that is
like dealing with an adult it's all like
dealing with a little kid when Donald
Trump goes overseas he has to be managed
like a kid because he'll get bored
meetings with world leaders the ones
he's invited to he's constantly on his
phone his attention drifts to a
television with Fox News on it at the
back of the room it would be really
great to have a president who doesn't
have to be treated like a child all the
time who's the adult in the room and you
know cauliflower and mashed potatoes
it's an almost irrelevant tip of the
iceberg but it all is part of managing
Trump like the little kid he behaves as
and by the way is is a little bit of
cauliflower in the mashed potatoes
actually going to help Donald Trump much
when he's obsessed with KFC and fast
food I'm just asking the question I get
that something is better than nothing
but I just don't know if mixing in a
florid of cauliflower florid or floret I
guess I'm never sure it mixing in a
piece of to of cauliflower into Donald
Trump's mashed potatoes is going to do
too much for him one way or the other
bizarre these are the times that we are
living in I want to give a quick shout
out to one of our sponsors VIN Charo
watches they're giving my audience 15%
off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been thinking about looking for
one to elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out vin chair oh it's an american
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even chair Oh watch ranges from
a hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the kairos in white and
silver really love the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really love this one they
also sent me the Kairos limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family anytime you see me wearing a
watch on the show I'm wearing a Ventura
watch go through their collection I know
you'll find something you like and
you'll get 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch